this is my family and i will not let you
take me away from them
[Music]
here we go
[Music]
a toast
to motherhood
and to new beginnings
[Music]
can i tell you something basically
sometimes i feel like i'm cursed i think
that everything's happening the way that
it's supposed to
this cult could come back for her at any
time none of you can protect me from
them
you wouldn't even know what to look for
are you feeding those squatters again
sean they're holding kids dorothy
what if they're casing the place
i forbid you to go back to that park
it's so funny how controlling you can be
i think would be best for everyone if
you were able to make peace with leanne
why are you both so afraid of her
she's angry
i see
please don't hurt her
julian you're not telling me everything
what is going on
what the hell happens now
the end
i don't want to lose my son again
things are decaying
she's got to go
the house is filled with pests
which is like this worm
that gets under your skin
this is my home
this is my family
and i will not let you take me away from
them
god didn't bring back
i jericho i did
[Music]
you